哈囉,我是爸爸們你們喊喊
我現在是當起床,然後就想還跟你們分享一下
我是怎樣消滅我連上的闇口的
這是我現在的闇口
那這個是我以前的闇口
我以前是一個非常非常愛長闇口的人
之前每週都是要去闇口診所去做真心的
然後每一次都可以進出好多好多東西來
但我現在去一個診所的話
你小姐姐說我連上已經沒有什麼東西了
就連下巴上那種
一裡黎摸起來非常粗糙的那個東西
現在也沒有個
現在就是偶爾忽不品沒有用好會
長一些小闇口
大部分也是那種開口型的
比科學是你擠他他就是那種小米蜜
然後他也不會發言也不會有硬子的那種
那現在我就來跟你們分享一下我是做的什麼呢
那我現在愛上闇口的女生毛孔
可是你是讓我一肚子來的
所以普通的清潔方法
清潔面目對你們來說可能不太夠
那你毛孔裡的油脂
他出不來呢
就會讓你長闇口
看起來有科裡感皮膚粗糙
我之前有出過一心獨家的深層清潔大法
用那個方法在配合你日常的護理
你就不會再也長必口了
因為你毛孔已經通了
然後很多寶寶看了之後就做了
然後給我反規說效果非常的好
現在又研發出了一個2.0的版本
我試看我韓國的皮膚整索是這麼做的
就是我之前去他們都是先給我真清再給我用紛
我覺得他的原理就是你物理真清過的毛孔
再給他用紛的效果會更好毛孔
然後會更長通
你是我在使用完我的那個深層清潔大法之後
我想說那我也來搞不算試一下吧
有了這款動模
我選他的原因是因為我覺得他非常的溫和
使用算他本身就是有一個書充毛孔的功能
他還有殺君消眼的功效
我想我這樣子我計完的時候
不是還有一點點紅紅的滿剛好
使用算來跟我殺君消眼了
我發現用我身體清潔大法配合
使用雖然這你只能看到皮膚偷偷別的氣泥
毛孔和黑頭能夠乾淨百分之左是八八八
我不說買了左是八還是可以的
那第二件我就是推薦艾賞必口的寶寶
你們可以在你的護膚品當中加一個酸辣的精華
我自己就是一個超級受益者
你毛孔董塞的原因就是一個是你的角質層太厚了
讓裡面的油脂
他出不來
我們用第一個方法去物理的那把毛孔的油脂
給他清楚來之後
你在用酸辣的產品加受你皮膚
角質層比較厚的區域
讓他角質快速的波拖
那這樣不就是肚子的必口了
我之前要給你們分享過一個我很喜歡的這個肉酸清滑
但是它不好買的而且它真的是比較猛
很多寶寶能都不能用
那我皮膚還會用一下這種性人酸
我之前皮膚整索的衣生給我開的酸就是性人酸
我對性人酸的印象非常的好
它不僅可以加速漲脂的波拖
它還有幻膚的功能
必口的寶寶你們應該知道
平滑對我們來說是多麼的來自不一樣
它現在很能和
但是它的效果有非常好
而這款我是在水之後
在擦擦擦擦各個幾滴把災害
我腳就比較厚的區域
之後我再用一個清爽的舒服清滑
再加一個清爽的面双就OK了
讓我就不怕是會把我的皮膚給刷敏感了
第三點如果臉上已經有必口斗斗的寶寶們
你們只接去做真心
這個是最快速最有效傷害最小的方法
而且真心它也不貴
這是我九年以來總結的一個晶天
就是有的時候你不要想的
就是用一個什麼金滑
什麼都可以把它擦美
一般這種金滑都是很酸的
你想要去把那個必口給擦美
它是有可能
但是它那個時間會很久
而且你不知道你是以一個
幫助的形式讓它沒有斷
還是讓它只增消失
所以真心是最快速有效的方法
真心滿之後可以休息三到五天
就可以用我開始收的方法了
好啦我劇必口的方法已經都分享給你們囉
希望對你們有幫助
拜拜